hello future chess players this is
international master David Cruz for
chess comm and today I will be teaching
you one of the exception rules in chess
which is capturing all puzzle and all
pass all is false a4 in passing and it
is the one capturing chess where your
piece does not end up on the square of
the piece it captured usually in chess
if you were going to capture a piece you
would pick up a piece of yours that was
going to do the capture you would pick
up a piece of the opponent's that you
were going to capture and then you would
put your piece down where that piece had
been and that's how all captures work
basically it's just you walk onto the
square where the other piece was and
then you remove it but on pestle is the
one exception to that and it is a
special move where the other person's
pawn moves to spaces like this and then
you capture their pawn with the pawn
next to it as if they had only moved one
square so it looks like this now let me
take you back in chess history a little
bit and explain to you where this move
comes from to help you remember it and
then we'll just go over it a couple more
times so chess used to have a rule that
pawns could move one space at a time now
they can move two spaces if they are on
the second rank or the seventh rank
right so it used to be pawns could move
one step at a time and so what you would
see is you would see the pawns moving
like this slowly towards each other and
then finally they'd come into contact
and now these two pawns either one could
capture the other and the battle starts
well at some point people's attention
spans really decreased and they decided
that they couldn't wait this long to
start the battle right so they added the
rule that pawns could move two steps at
a time but a very very important thing
about pawns is whether they're passed
pawns are not passed pawns so it's a
very important question whether
spawn here could walk all the way down
to the board and become a queen with
this pawn never being able to capture it
that's a very very important question if
you have any way to get past this pawn
so theoretically you shouldn't have any
way to get past it see no matter how I
move the white or black pawns at some
point there comes a move where they
could capture each other right if I move
them two steps at a time there still
comes a point where they could capture
each other so these are not passed pawns
their pawns which still have an opposing
pawn that could get them so that brings
us to this guy over here is he a passed
pawn no there is a pawn on the
neighboring file and he should not be
able to walk all the way down the board
and become a queen without this pawn
having the chance to capture him on his
trip but let's say he makes this move
how's this pawn supposed to capture him
right he's legally this pawn is only
supposed to capture on these two squares
so did this guy just run right past him
so they decided that that would mess up
the way chess played too much so instead
of allowing the pawn to run past like
that they decided to create an extra
rule which is to capture in passing so
when upon passes you by you can capture
it by moving as if it had only gone one
step now this option is only available
for one move you don't have the option
to capture on a3 for the rest of the
game
you can't like move your King and their
pawn keeps going and you're doing
something with your King attacking this
pawn and they come here and suddenly you
realize that this pawn is going to
become a queen so you move your pawn to
a3 and say I capture your pawn in
passing absolutely not
you can't even do that if their pawn
remains on a4 and they now move their
King you can't suddenly realize wait I
should capture their pawn it's a
one-time option okay so it's just saying
the pawn can't go past you without you
having the right to capture it for a
moment but if you won't take that right
if you won't exercise it it's taken away
from you like so many other rights so
the pawn if it goes past you you've got
a one move window in which you can
capture it behind like this all right so
now let me ask you a question
let's say this pawn here and this pawn
can this pawn captured that pawn I'll
pass on by going to the d4 square yes or
no the answer is no this pawn here is
not a pawn that has just moved two
spaces right in fact all captures all
pass all must occur with a pawn that has
just gone from the second rank to the
fourth rank right and the pawn that
captures it has to be on the fifth rank
and then take it okay so how about this
black please this move can white capture
this pawn on pestle if you answered yes
you now understand how to capture on
pestle and I'm very happy for you okay
so one more quick question just to check
on your full understanding so black has
a pawn on c4 and now white moves their
pawn from d3 to d4 is black allowed to
capture that pawn on pestle because the
pawn is on the right rank and the white
pawn is now on the right rank as well
can black capture it like this the
answer is no because this pawn has only
moved one step all pass all is only when
that pawn rushes past you by moving two
steps not when it moves one I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess calm